[موسيقى]
لم تعد الامور كما كانت عليه هنا في سالوي
اكثر المناطق غنى بالاسماك في السنغال
ينطلق موسى ورفاقه في رحله صيد جديده
لا يكف كلالها عن التدمر بعد ان اصبحت
اماكن كثيره محظوره على الصيادين
تم تشييدها في منطقه اعتدنا على ممارسه
الصيد فيها حيث كنا نتوجه الى هناك بخمس
مئه زورق على الاقل والان منعنا من الوصول
اليها
طيب هذه دخلت الحيز الجغرافي الذي تستخدمه
شركات اجنبيه لاستخراج النفط والغاز ما
اثر سلبا على حياه شريحه واسعه من سكان
السانوي
تظهر الاحصائيات ان لدينا 45 ترخيصا للصيد
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي سنويا ومجموع
التراخيص التي قمنا بمنحها يقدر ب 150
هذه الوعود ليست جديده على سكان سلوي
فخلال فتره الاستعمال الفرنسي عرفت
المدينه كعاصمه للغرب الافريقي ومنها عبرت
البواخر الاوروبيه لتجاره الذهب والرقيق
والعاج
وهذا الماضي الاستعماري لا يزال حاضرا في
الاذهان
بدات الشعوب الافريقيه عن مصالحها وتستيقظ
لتفهم انا الاستثمارات الاوروبيه لا تدر
الارباح الافريقيه بدليل انه لم تحصل
تطورات كبيره منذ الاستقلال في الستينيات
القرن الماضي فالاستثمارات تكون لمصلحه
الدول الاوروبيه
مع ترقبي بدء انتاج الغاز المسالي وتصدير
البترول ترتفع اصوات سكان القرى والمناطق
المتاخمه لمواقع الانتاج رافضه ما تراه
انعكاسات سلبيه للتنقيب على البيئه
والثروه السمكيه خصوصا في مدينه سلوي على
الحدود السنغاليه الموريتانيه
حضور الدول الغربيه في السنغال يدور الان
في محور اخر فالتنافس على اشده عبر بوابه
الطاقه هنا في حقل حميم الكبير على الحدود
مع موريتانيا الذي يقدر احتياطي بعشرين
التريليون قدم مكعبه من الغاز الطبيعي
المسال تسعود شركه بيبي البريطانيه على
نسبه 60% منه
وتشير التوقعات الى ان حقل حميم سيشهد بيع
الشحنه الاولى منه نهايه عام 2023
فمع ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا التي خلفتها
الحرب في اوكرانيا كثافه الحكومات
الاوروبيه وعلى راسها فرنسا جهودها في
افريقيا ففي السنغال فازت شركه توتال
الفرنسيه بصفقه تسمح لها بتقاسم الارباح
من حقل اخر فيسك وذلك بقيمه تجاوزت
مليارات الدولارات
هذا السعي المحموم من قبل الاوروبيين
ينعكس داخل السنغال بمقاربه مختلفه
[موسيقى]
امامنا افاق جميله ويبقى السنغال منفتحا
على كل انواع الشراكه سواء اكان ذلك مع
الشركات الاوروبيه ام الاسيويه ام في
الشرق الاوسط وكذلك مع الشركات الامريكيه
نحافظ على نهجنا في توسيع علاقاتنا
الدوليه
وبينما تتحدث الحكومه السنغاليه عن ان
عقودها مع الشركات الاوروبيه تضمن لها
ارباحا تتجاوز 60% تتهم المعارضه الحكومه
بمحاباه الاوروبيين على حساب الشركات
الدوليه الاخرى
فيما يتعلق بتوزيع الثروات ينبغي على
الحكومه السنغاليه الحرص على توزيع هذه
الثروات المرتقبه وبالغه الاهميه على نحو
جيد ينبغي استخدامها في مجال التصنيع
للتمكن من الاستفاده القصوى من هذه
المصادر
وبعيدا عن البحر انفتحت الحكومه السنغاليه
على شركاء من خارج الدائره الاوروبيه
الضيقه في مقدمتهم الصين عبر مشاريعها
بمليارات الدولارات في مجال البنيه
التحتيه
وفق الحكومه السنغاليه بلغ حجم التبادل
التجاري مع الصين مستوى قياسيا عام 2022
ليتخطى 4 مليارات دولار
ورغم ذلك لا تزال فرنسا المستثمر الاول في
السنغال حيث ساهمت مؤخرا في تمويل اول
قطار سريع بتكلفه تصل الى نحو مليار يورو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على تطوير برنامج بالغ الاهميه يشمل تشييد
2700 كيلو متر من الطرق المعبده في
المقاطعات الخمس والاربعين في السنغال
انها سياسه فك العزله وتسهيل الحركه
والربط بين المدن ومختلف الاقطاب
الاقتصاديه
تقدم السنغال نموذجا عماله في افريقيا بين
اللاعبين التقليديين والقادمين الجدد
فبعدما كانت اوروبا وفي مقدمتها فرنسا
القوه لوحدها في القاره حيث تتحكم
بالانظمه ووجودها تجد نفسها اليوم في
مواجهه قوى كبرى دخلت الى افريقيا بادوات
مختلفه ومقاربه جديده
لتتحول القاره من ساحه حصريه لاوروبا الى
مساحه تنافس يشهد فيها المستعمر التاريخي
لحفظ ما تبقى له من نفوذ
[موسيقى]
الجزيره السنغال